i mean but that's part of it you're
putting
so much heart so much blood and heart
and sweat and
every your whole meaning of life becomes
winning
so and sometimes it's so hard to lose
within that context so
if in your i think the first wrestling
life you wrote about
chad zappato who lost
i mean an incredible wrestler but lost
in three finals
in the nationals and has this tattoo of
a uh hawk clawing out the human heart
yeah so what lessons
is there any lessons from the
incredible wrestling he's done but also
the incredible suffering that he went
through
on himself yeah again you like that word
suffering
which is okay okay no no no no no keep
it keep it because it fits right in
where i want yeah
i have to turn that suffering around
yeah
to where he makes and feels good about
himself
are better does not feel perfect yeah
because he did lose yeah you know and so
but you have to actually get him to
realize
that yeah he's still unique compared to
the walk of the earth
he was unbelievably unique right at the
top just
a little bit short of but because it was
you know he felt the suffering you now
have to go about and change that and
put it into good will some way and
because he's you really have a lot of
good will
you can do a lot of good well and so
and it's not easy it took him probably
years years of tattooing
yeah years of covering the tattoos
and you know he told me moved to keller
i go why are you moving to california
because he was here
for a couple years after his wrestling
was done because he had a good job
around here and he was
i thought he was doing a good job but he
he just he said i had to
escape you know it's the same as the
wrestling tattoo i had a wrestling
terminology i have to get i
i hate to say this i hate to say this
i go where are you going he said i'm
gonna go to california
and i go is there any reason why you go
into california
he says that's where everybody goes to
hide
but i said i think you're wrong there
but
you know i think you what will determine
your life will be
what you do from now on you know and if
you can and he's actually turned it
around
i mean he's actually turned around you
have to discover that yourself exactly
and he went someplace that he thought
he could fit into and i think he did
and i think he's got a good job and he's
helping people and
he covered that tattoo with uh feathers
uh another tattoo well in the end it's a
beautiful story
the idea is it really is suffering and
overcoming yeah and he's
not done yet he's not done yet no he's
not done he he's
got a lot more to do
you